よろしくお願いします
あの 今日のテーマはこの前も一応
一回やったことがありまして
まあ人間というのは知識能力っていうのは欲しがるし
まあそれは別に欲しがってはいけないということではなくて
まあ知識能力の力で生きてますからね
ですから開発しなくちゃいけないしね
そういうことを言っても
大体まあ我々は知識やら能力やらね
すごく堕落するような生き方はしています
で まああの宣伝しているところでは
頭とか頭脳とか書いてありましたけど
仏教では別に頭脳についてはそんな興味あるわけじゃないんです
それは体の一部ですから
まあ一応心ということになります
で 心で言っても あまり心は何やとわからないんだから
まあ認識ということで理解しておきます
認識のスピードは皆に同じです
早いんです で 認識する場合は遅い人
早い人はいません 誰でも同じスピードで認識するんです
それっていうのは心の法則で
特別に遅い心 早い心っていうのはあるわけじゃないんです
もののスピードは一応決まっている
ですから こういうちょっとした実験でこれ考えればわかると思いますね
目の前に何かオブジェクトを置いておいて
目を閉じる 閉じた瞬間に目を開けてまた閉じる
そのオブジェクトどれぐらい早く認識できるのかと時間を測ってみてください
これは誰でも同じスピードなんですよ
だから認識するスピードはまあ
測ることはできないほど早いと思います
決してあの今のあるストップウォッチとかでは測らないかもしれません
目を開けて閉じて開ける
閉じるぐらいの瞬間だからね
この開けて閉じる間で
あのものは見えてます
かなり早く見えてます
それからこのいろいろこの心理テストなんかする場合でも
まあそういう実験的にやってます
例えばモニター画面でなんとかなんとか見えるものはこういうものを見えますよと
例えば人間見えますよと
で 男見たらまあ何かボタンを押してくださいというふうな感じにするんですけど
そこで男と女で何か全く他のものも背景でサーッと流れているんです
流れているんだけど 本人はそれを認識しないんですね
ボタンを押さないんです
押さないんだけど 脳にはそれでも全部記録されていますよと
大体は 1 秒の2 3ぐらいですね
これも大体の話で あの 1 秒の2 3ぐらいでも見えちゃいます
人によって早い人も遅い人もいると思われるでしょうが
実は皆に同じ速さで視覚が起こるんです
味覚 嗅覚 体の感覚の場合は微妙な差があり得る
他の場合は微妙な差があり得るんです
例えば味覚の場合は かなり厳密に接触しないと味は感じないんですね
だから それは舌の形とかね
唾液のコンテンツとかね
そういうものによって差があり得るかもしれません
そういうものもやっぱり育てられますよ
すごい敏感になれるようにと
で 味覚のプロがいるでしょう
嗅覚のプロもいるしね
そういう人々にはもう犬のように嗅覚があるんですよ
嗅覚でいろいろ商売していますね
嗅覚  うん まあそういう人々もいますよ
もうびっくりするほど
例えば何かテレビで見たんですけど
いろいろミネラルウォーター
ガラスに入れておいて
これ嗅いで銘柄言ってくださいと
ちゃんと言うんですよ
だからこれは犬以外は言えないと思いますけど
犬に言ったって犬は名前わかりませんだからね
ですから そういう人々はその自分の嗅覚をまあ育てています
では 遅くなるのはいつでしょうかと
だから論理的には誰でも同じなんです
認識はスピードは法則的には
しかし 実際は遅い人もいますね
何？それは何を見えたかと伺う時なんですね
本人が見たことを見たんだけど ３
人が同じオブジェクトを見る ３
人には見えてますよ それ何見えたの？と聞いちゃうと答えがバラバラなんですね
そこで遅いということには言うだけでね
視覚は意識に変換する時ですね
そこでこの見たものは視覚ですね
それは意識に変換しなきゃいけないんですよ
そこは瞬時に起こるはずなんですけど
時間がかかっちゃうんですね
そちらで遅いという問題が出てくるんです
だからデータを意識化する
意識化する過程で問題が起こるんですよ
花は瞬間に見えるが 花ですと認識する時なんです
点が必要ですけど 時間がかかります
詳細に認識するときはさらに時間を取るんですね
花だと認識する時 時間かかりますけど
見えることは見える それでもっと明確に詳細に見ようとすると時間がかかるんですね
明確に明確に見る場合は時間がかかるという仮説が成り立ちますね
それでで 時間がかかるということは
明確に見る時ですよというふうに
これ仮説です これ やがて成立するか壊れるかわかりませんだけど
まあ一応一回見ただけのデータで明晰な認識は作れないんだから
何回何回も見て見て見てデータを積み重ねて
それで大量のデータが入ったらなんとか認識するということになります
そういうわけで 経験は認識
知識になる場合 明確に見るとは知識のことですね
知識っていうのは 生まれるんです
バラの花ですという場合はもう知識なんです
認識ではないんです 認識をもうもう変化していって
知識になっているんです
知識にするためには 見た花に関する過去のデータ
経験などが必要なんですね
見たものは 例えばバラの花だとするならば
花を見たんですよ これはバラの花ですと
知識にするためには過去のデータが必要なんです
過去の経験が必要なんですね
それは入った それは入ったデータのプログラミングです
あのプロセッシングですね
プログラミングではなくて
プロセッシングということはするんですね
コンピューターと同じで
見たものがあって 見たものは何ものかと知識にする
知識にする場合は 自分の心にある過去の経験
過去のデータ それは持っていってプロセッシングするんです
合成するんです 合成した結果に知識というんです
プロセッシングが終わったら知識という結果を出しますね
例えば 一回だけ小学校の時見た花があって
それで今の年になってまた見たら
あれ これは見たことがあるんだけどとか
時間かかりますよ 何の花というかね
なんか見た覚えがあるんですけどと
ずっと考えたところで
ああ わかった この小学校の時はもうあ
こういうこういう花ですよと
見たことがあります 結構時間かかってますよ
過去の経験を引き出して
それでプロセッシングするために
早い遅いはデータプロセッシングの問題です
だから知識が早いか遅いかということは
このデータプロセッシングの問題なんですね
別に心は遅い人間はいるわけじゃないんです
だからすごく頭が早く回転したければ
もうデータプロセッシングを
なんとかするしかないんです
それで心っていうのはデータバンクとして見事なデータバンクなんですよ
心は無量のデータを保管できるんです
リミットがないんです
で しかし このプロセッシングに引き出せる場合は
かなり昔のデータだったら
もうとっくに忘れているというのは忘れてないんですよ
引き出せない で 心はもう全部データバンクに入れておくんです
でも時間かかると引き出せないだけ
あの昨日では 昨日 輪廻転生について質問があって
まあ返事を出さないでいろいろごまかしをしましたけど
あの まあ科学的になんだらかんだとかね
まあそれはブッダが科学的に語っているならば
輪廻があるということは誰にでも実験すればわかるでしょうと
まあそれはわかりますけど
あいつは実験できるのかと
即席にしてもね やればできるんですけど
何でもできないでしょうにという答えで終わっちゃったんです
例えばピアノでも習っちゃえば誰にでもできますけどね
だからといってプロになれる？なれないでしょうに
なれる人もならない人もいる
やればできるということは論理
理論ですけど やっぱり自分自身がそれに適しているかいないかということは
別な話なんですね ですから
誰でも何か分野をね 自分にできる分野でプロになるんであって
何でもできることにならない
だからといって不可能という風には論理的には言えません
だから その能力ある人には過去のことを見る
経験することはできますけど
だからといってもう誰にでもできると言っちゃうともね
一番難しい課題でしょうね
だからそういうちょっとした問題があります
そこで それについて難しい話があるんですよ
なんでお釈迦様にもう無量の過去を見られたんでしょうかと
人の生滅というか 生死見えたんでしょうかと
これは幻覚ではないかと
その人 そういう風に もしかするとそれは主観の幻覚ではないかという風にも疑問を出しましたけどね
質問自体はちゃんと論理的にできてやった質問ですけど
しかし 説明はその方々にはするのは難しいんですね
例えばこちら怪肉会館だよという
こちら皆様集まって座ってるんだよということは
私はもう知ってるでしょ
それは私の心に記録されています
だからあと十年経ったところで
その心を引き出してみれば
同じ場面が出るんです
それだけのこと だから自分の心の過去を引き出すだけなんです
で 記録しています 出しても宇宙の全部秘密入ってますよ
過去における出来事とか
だからそこはもう引くということですよ
だからお釈迦様は自分の過去を見る場合は
このすべて性別 何食べたか
どんな性格でしたか 寿命はどうでしたかとかね
どんな生き方をしたのかとか
どんな行為をしたのかとか
それはすごい明確にね
見るんだと 例えば我々は何か 1週間
1ヶ月とか 1年前でやったこと
経験したことを思い出す場合は
それって幻覚ですかね
幻覚じゃないんです そういう余計な妄想
感情 観念 あれこれはごまかし
解説とかね これだからこのあれだからなるとか
あれがなければ幻覚でなくちゃんと見えるんですよ
満杯ということは論理的にはないんです
心は満杯になりません
実際はあり得るという意味なんですね
まあ人によって満杯になることはあり得るんですけど
論理的には心はデータ入れても入れても入れても
あ もう終わり もう満杯
もう 1つのハードディスク買ってくださいということになりません
心にデータが丁寧に保管される
それだけじゃないんですよ
このデータ保管はものすごく丁寧に行うんです
そうすると なんでそうなるのかと疑問するでしょうね
それはもう論理性に欠けています
物事というのは丁寧でなきゃ保管できません
例えば針の上で玉を置くということはありえないでしょうに
倒れちゃいますね だからこの自然の中では
物事はとても丁寧に積み重ねていくんです
心も自然なんです だから自然見ても自然に放っておけば
すべて見事に丁寧にバランスを整えて生きているんです
この自然の中で崩れちゃうと
それで崩れてまた元に戻るんですよ
木の木に大きな実が乗っていて
これは別に何のことなく落ちませんよ
いくら大きいものであっても
日本では大きい実がないんですけど
自分の家では 20キロとか 30キロのジャックフルーツとかかなり重いんですよ
あれは細いヘタで何のことなく持ってます
なんで細いヘタにこれを重いものは持てるかというと
それは自然だからなんです
小さい時は本当に小さいんですけど
どんどん大きくなってくると
ヘタのところもどんどんそれなりに強くなって強くなって同時に
だからちょうどいい強さでいつでもあるんです
そこでもう熟したら もうこれはもう木は捨てなくちゃいけないんですね
そうすると とても美しく
繋がっているところで外れるんですよ
すごくスムーズに で 我々
これとこれ ヘタと実を見たら
どうやってこれ繋げていたんでしょうかと
不思議で不思議でしょうがないかもしれませんだけど
糊も何もないのにとかね
それって別に不思議じゃないんです
それは自然の流れですから
落ちる実が落ちる時は破れて落ちるわけじゃないんです
ちゃんと外れて落ちるんです
葉っぱでも 大抵葉っぱぐらい見てください
葉っぱついてるところは破れてないでしょうに
すごく丁寧に外れてるんです
だから木にも毛がないし
傷ないし 葉っぱにも傷がないんです
だからこの自然の中で
この積み重ねっていうのはとても丁寧に起きてますよ
まあ大きな木なんか見てみると
枝なんかすっごいでしょう
重さは でも見事にバランスを整えてしっかりしています
しっかりしていない木は倒れます
倒れたところでまた自然なんです
そういうことで ありがたいことに
心にデータはもういい加減に入るわけじゃないんです
ちゃんと丁寧に入るんです
他のデータの関連性も引き出せるようなインデックスも作っておくんです
この我々は認識するたびに認識がデータバンクに入るんですよ
同時にインデックスも入っているんです
どうやって引き出せるか
仏教の心理学でアビダンマでは
まあそういうところはものすごくうるさく説明はしていますけどね
が 頭の悪い人ばかりですね
世界は こんな見事な心を持ってるんですけど
世の中を見ると そんな頭の人っていうのはね
いるわけじゃないんです
何でも見事に過去を思い出せるとかはいませんね